okay guys now it is time to meet team
arrow
please welcome BuzzFeed's Jaret Wisel
men who will take us through some
pointed conversations with the arrow
cast and producers hi guys how are you
you I am so excited to be here that I'm
dropping water because I am such a huge
fan of the first show we have coming up
tonight do we have other arrow fans in
Hall age right now I think she's a fan
anything to meet Ian Somerhalder I swear
um okay
keep that applause going we are going to
bring out the men and women behind arrow
right now first up chief creative
officer for DC entertainment Geoff Johns
next up executive producer Greg Berlanti
star Paul Blackthorne
start David Ramsey
a little lady by the name of Emily BETT
Rickards Oliver Queen himself stephen
amell give it up for Katie Cassidy keep
it going
Willa Holland perhaps he's reformed we
don't know John Barrowman next we have
executive producer Wendy Marissa
executive producer Marc Guggenheim and
last but by no means least executive
producer Andrew Kreisberg guys give it
up for team arrow
all right we're gonna jump right into
this because time is limited and we have
to talk about that suit Stephen that new
suit is bomb it is amazing Jonathan I
don't know what you're talking about
though that was not I forget what how
does it compare to the other suits
you've worn um well first of all we need
to give credit to Maya meny is I may
have pronounce her last name wrong MA
and I sorry but she has made every
single suit on our show since the
original arrow costume and she's up in
Vancouver right now I hope she gets to
see this she's done such a bang-up job
everything that the producers the
creators the writers me John asked her
to do for the suit
she did it and she nailed it you guys
like it good but I would love to know
because it seems like he's battle-ready
I mean Berlanti how does the suit factor
in to season four well I think we've
ordered sort of always said that the
progression for Oliver is is very much
from the arrow to green arrow and this
is the first real real step in that
direction I think it's a it expresses
sort of who he's going to be
more than necessarily who he's been on a
series I said Andrew I mean if you could
sort of expand upon that how does that
play into the tone of the new season um
you know I I think you know this the
show isn't gonna suddenly become a
comedy um but uh you know I think
there's a young you know there's
certainly at the end of that clip you
saw Oliver driving off into the sunset
so when the season starts he's in a much
better place he's happy he's in love and
you know I think that that that uh you
know that that that feeling kind of
infuses all the characters there's a
little bit more fun this year a little
bit more humor but it still takes place
on rooftops and still shooting arrows
and still takes place in the rain and
Wendy I mean in the writers room
whatwhat is getting you guys excited
about that that new sort of phase that
Andrews talking about um well we
actually get to have Oliver make some
jokes in the lair which is a first so
that's really fun and it's just it's
been as Greg was saying part of uh you
know all of his evolution and part of
the journey of his character to see him
in love and see what it's like for him
to be in a relationship and also be
working with someone who's part of his
superhero mission absolutely uh it was
announced the other day jeff that damian
darhk-- is gonna be a part of the new
season very exciting what can you tell
us about bringing in this new comic book
character to the world of arrow uh I
really started with I think a
conversation with mark about what what
villains would come into arrow and
there's a big one coming
I don't another big one coming beyond
damian darhk-- but damien darhk's a
villain from the titans and he's got a
big crew behind him but there's a lot of
an in air there's a lot of characters
coming up that that people won't really
guess that are gonna come from the DC
Universe that will appear soon mark do
you want to add anything to that
anything to anything to talking about
perhaps these new characters and their
characters well you know perhaps we've
got a few we've got a gentleman who will
be joining Damien um Batman fans know
him as anarchy really excited about and
you know one of the things that we like
to do on arrow is tell the secret
origins of various characters
you got to see how you know Roy Harper
became Arsenal you got to see how Laurel
became the Black Canary Thea became
speedy
this year we want to introduce a new
character to the you know arrow you know
show mr. terrific anything you any want
anything that you can tell us beyond the
name coming into the world writers uh
he's gonna work with Felicity be a good
friend of hers we're often asked about
when we're going to add another LGBTQ
character to the show and our version of
mr. terrific happens to be gay I love it
uh mark was talking a little bit about
sort of everyone's evolutions and Katie
this was a huge year for you on the show
we saw her go from the darker she's ever
been to outfitted in some bad ass
leather I mean what excited you about
finally getting to put on that suit
after three years everything the PA
system is super excited about it yeah
really so I got the yeah yeah everyone
agrees I guess I don't know what that
means uh I'm really excited
I'm obviously I mean you know it's been
I feel like it's been a long time coming
but it absolutely was worth the wait and
I think it was great you know the way
the writers took the character and and
the way they wrote for me was fantastic
and it just made it that much more
legitimate and that much more realistic
and made me that much more excited about
it absolutely yeah speaking of things
that were a long time coming Willa Mae
officially call you speedy now you may
that's the first time I've ever seen a
shot of me and the outfit actually is
right there
it's a good look I'm staring at it and I
can't keep my head um why is it on my
body right now uh when they sort of came
down that you would be getting in the
suit for real for good what excited you
about this next phase in Thea's life
um I again like Katie said absolutely
everything uh but just being able to do
justice to the origin story of a female
character going from you know troubles
to being lied to - trying to grow up get
her stuff together failing at it a
little bit then being lied to a bit more
here and there having your father come
into her life maybe think it's gonna be
okay then it fails some more and then
you know she just why - again like haha
there's just like all this stuff she
goes through but normally when you see
that on television or film it's usually
a woman who doesn't really come back up
from that so it's been absolutely a
beyond honour to play a strong female
character who's come out the other side
and is in some red clouded leather um
yeah it's been absolutely the greatest
that's ever happened my life and I had
tears of joy when I tried on the outfit
for the first time guys that's my girl
yeah daddy's proud I think that's very
understandable you know for talking
about costumes there was a moment
towards the end of last season when I
pretty much fell out of my chair and I
think that was when Felicity landed in
the atoms oh dear God gia Gunn Emily
what was it like being in that suit uh
well I'll tell you a little secret
that's not so much a secret I only wore
the upper half of the suit it was
actually Brandon's suit I was wearing a
lot of hockey pads underneath um as well
as a men's shorts leotard on an Apple
box and the turnaround shot when Stephen
is smiling lovingly into my eyes he's
actually looking at a six foot four
stunt man
I it was gorgeous handsome fellow um but
I like I was behind the screens going
over just like oh like right into Mike's
eyes and that that was probably
priceless
um wearing that suit was awesome rant
like B has a he's got a lot of not wait
I would say but it's rich it's stiff I
mean it's an awesome suit but he's I
mean he's got an attitude like I've
never seen that guy is always positive
and he's wearing that suit with that cow
um but super cool I love it
speaking of cows John are you gonna be
officially ditching the hoods for like
long lengthy robes now that you are Ross
I don't know but I got the ring um I
don't really know if I'll be ditching
the row you know the hood for the robes
it's that's what I think is exciting
about being part of this show and these
guys know as do my my fellow actors on
the show they know I don't like to know
what's going to happen too far ahead I
like to be surprised cuz I'm a big nerd
and geek myself and I get the scripts go
okay it's only awesome so um I'm not
sure what's gonna happen you know
obviously I do know some things but
we'll see am I going to keep the hood or
am I gonna keep the long cage you're
gonna grater to keep the long cape but
you're gonna get back into the hood for
episode three awesome yeah awesome so
and will I wear the this is the thing
you know will I wear the ring yeah
that's just any so long as you're Ra's
al Ghul you can wear the range I'm so
glad I had this one made for myself haha
I love that uh I did you're never
getting it back
if we're talking about ditching stuff I
know you guys go back to work like
officially on Monday David are they
gonna make you uh shave we got a little
hiatus scruff happening what's that
about you guys like the scruff I like
Emily Emily do you like Jeff I like the
scruff I like he'll be shaving that's
what's up
well you know I don't I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to keep the scruff
because I don't know if it'll go well
with my new helmet Oh
Diggle has officially gotten a costume
yeah it's called black driver do you
know we heard today sorry to interrupt
but I have to say I never consoled
Oliver Oliver the bromance never before
has a boy what did you mark what no this
is the right time to get Diggle in a
uniform like that well you know one of
the things that we started to feel last
year and we dressed this on the show is
diggle's got a wife he's got a daughter
and if he's going out there surrounded
by people in masks and he's you know
John Diggle uh it's not the greatest
idea on his part so I think Oliver's
advice last year too you know dude cover
up your face of it I was well taken that
and David said he would kill us if we
didn't give him a costume yeah I did say
that so then everyone on the stage now
Felicity borrows hers but Paul I feel
like we got to get you in some sort of
leather band X number III have this
really nice suit it'sit's a grey suit
and I got a white shirt and it's stripy
tie this year
what about that my outfit superhero
stuff um yeah I'm still gonna regular
costume fittings myself but uh you know
that's okay Lancel in quite some angle
better hero status yet I don't know if
that's really on the cards uh but we
shall see yellowy spandex
well let me ask you know there was sort
of his loyalties to Oliver over the last
season really changed a lot he was
opposed now he's on do you officially
consider yourself part of team arrow now
well I don't have able to officially
ever consider himself part of team arrow
just for himself but uh I don't know it
sort of been the last five months it's
obviously been team - arrow and Lance's
had to reconcile with this this idea
this new Bunch
walking around with just this kind of
sulking leader you just see Lee sulking
a lot in this about remoting linen.i do
soak a lot but I look good he does look
good when he soaks it kind of pouts a
bit well then the new alpha looks nice
it helps hey Paul do you want to join
the league sagen I got a job for you the
league if you want one
Thank You Jessica nice yeah I can borrow
with it yeah I got a couple outfits in
my closet you can Roger yeah thank you
Donna
daddy so we're gonna open it up to your
questions in a minute I think there's a
line and a mic but before I do Stephen
and Emily congratulations are in order
olicity was crowned ship of the year I
believe at the MTV fandom the Lord
cookies you guys voted that for them uh
Stephen what does it mean to have this
partnership recognized so intensely by
the fans that they voted it over every
other relationship on television well it
first of all it means that we've been
around for a while you know we're going
into our fourth season and in this day
and age that's I mean that's that's
rarefied air it airs it's not
supernatural air but it's rarefied air
and there have been a ton of different
elements that people have had the
opportunity and the time to become
passionate about so the fact that so
many of you reached out and made this
happen for Emily and myself in the show
it really does mean a lot like not quite
an Emmy but it means a lot
ah what about for you Emily what does it
mean for me well let me tell you it this
is really cool we're we are we are going
into our fourth season and I've said
this before that passion feeds passion
and getting to come here which we do get
to do every year in it also it started
to unite us as well because it's always
the start of our season and coming into
something like that when you see the
passion that you guys have fed into you
guys are the best fandom I have to say
yeah absolutely
sometimes it's hard to articulate or
respond because it seems a little
strange door distant and then we get
here and this love is so parent and we
want to express all of us want
expressive we just love you guys too and
that's what we appreciate we appreciate
that you guys are having us hello
alright we they have a jam-packed night
here at Warner Brothers but let's get a
couple of questions in do we have one
ready to go oh it's over there hi hi hi
hello are you periscoping okay make sure
not feel like you could be no what's
your question uh I actually was the
first question on this panel last year
and it was even a meal question I didn't
like my answer so I'm gonna ask it again
okay it's not a good setup to get a
better answer by the way but okay for a
year so I thought I'd ask it you know
what the definition of insanity is right
okay what's your question oh well I know
Oliver Queen's super series on the show
so is he gonna become a little more
silly sarcastic like the green arrow in
the comics I mean I did just ask
everyone to follow the green arrow so I
think that we are going to move in a
more green arrow we direction in a more
green guys you're here next year by the
way I'm gonna be super mad
I'm tradition out thanks a lot
next question I don't know if you
remember me but um you traveled all the
way from the Emirates in the last two
days 24 hours to come but you exactly
yep I remember you thank you so much
so David Ramsey created a problem at
comic-con he was sold out all the Green
Lantern comic books because they say
you're the next Lantern hmm and then
Oliver are you getting to be a
billionaire again or you still you know
what broke okay you can put it below
yeah well universal symbol for broke
clearly I'll I'll go I'll go one better
I I have a sugar mama
hahaha he's right it does it's true way
to naturally hi um I want to say I love
you guys I love the show so much my
question mainly for the actors was there
ever a scenario where you had to be your
character in real life even for a short
time assist you know conquer anything I
hope not
anyone did we ever heard anybody has
anyone ever done I would I once I like I
once uh got mad at a guy at a hockey
game and he started talking back to me
and some guy yelled out from behind hey
that's the green arrow and it looked at
the kind I was like yeah I am I am the
first time ever k Lots came over to my
apartment in Vancouver I was trying to
figure out how I couldn't find my Apple
TV remote cuz it's like the size of this
looks like a spoon so I was like looking
around my kitchen like where is it and
she's like well you know you could just
put on your phone 60 of course I know
that
hey that and I had to pretend like I was
like huh
I love you I think we have time for one
more question
um yeah gene uh you have definitely not
failed this city
so my question goes up to the panel for
you guys what character dynamic
relationship between all of you will be
contrasted like in how heavy it would
like hit each other within you guys like
as and just relay as in like your own
personality towards each other I guess
what really I want to trick you it say
it again basically more concise okay say
it again you got basically what's your
main deal in your dynamic next season
dad we can look forward to an aztlán
within each other's characters okay yeah
yep okay I got that I got that yeah
we're getting close I know more family
oriented i am i go suiting the bullet
here on the reading the i've read the
first two episodes is it more of a
family orientation i'm kind of looking
at you but i don't really know if you
know the answer
we totally on it like when you look at
me just love looking in your eyes john I
would love I would love to see more of
the sparring if I'm just honest I'd love
to see more sparring between Malcolm and
um
Felicity cuz some of the to the stuff
that we got to do in the lot you know
last season it was quite fun to have
that and to see her kind of stand up and
you know when she was giving the orders
and Malcolm was going like okay I'll go
and do that now I also kind of cool
strong female roles are totally awesome
they're just
we love the strong female role I know
you girls you know they're all so
there's no one there's no one on on the
panel within the regulars of the series
that are in any way being kept in the
dark or or think that Oliver Queen is
just Oliver Queen or that I know them
Sara Lance is just Sara Lance so
everyone knows everyone's business and
that leads to I think some new
interactions that we'll get this year
like Malcolm and Felicity and like
Laurel and Thea a little bit more and
all of all of this good stuff it's that
new stuff in a fourth season is good mmm
nice well I can't think of a better
place to say thank you to team arrow for
being here with us tonight give it up
for them guys thank you so much and
everybody stay where you are there's a
lot more coming your way
you